de $1000 atendem ser um
E aí
você tenha gostado se tem alguém aqui
pessoal está dentro de casa com certeza
é
o
Olá pessoal
aqui
com o peixe
não
eu sei que são cinco da manhã mas hoje
nesta madrugada é nós vamos jogar aos
com desconto aqui na casa e vamos ter um
prêmio pessoal mil dos homens a quem
vencer
vai momento
eu ia eu ia de férias não sei
eu utilizava a minha placa graça né
[Música]
e eu eu comprava já um iPhone Olha como
é que tá aí as coisas aqui no Senhor
Comigo está bem ainda não colocou eu não
consigo
[Aplausos]
eu acho que vou de férias para alugar
para
Então a primeira Ronda vai ser só para
treinar o ultimate encontrado ganha $100
Ok só se podem esconder no perímetro da
casa e a segunda regra é que vocês tem
que levar o vosso telemóvel e filmar
tudo Onde estão escondidos as reações
tudo não tenho uma pergunta se eu
trouxer o carro para dentro próximos com
dentro do carro
responder vocês apenas tem 30 segundos
para se esconder o único sítio que não
vale é na cozinha que é onde eu vou
contar Ok olha a cozinha vocês podem
Esconder em qualquer lugar dentro e fora
de casa comecem os jogos ou 21
e
três quatro todos pegar um máscaras e
vamos esconder Ok
sete oito vou
estar o Dark é uma do caso não possa
carregar
16 17
19 21
É
sim
26 a
a
28 29
30 aqui vamos nós vamos ver quem é que
ganha Jacques em dólar
é que ser um bolo para se esconder já
aqui em cima na sala não me digam que
tem aqui Alguém baixo desta mesa já
sei que tem aqui alguém eu vou confirmar
já eu tenho quase certeza que ninguém
respondeu aqui esqueçam aqui a zona da
sala agora tenho duas opções ou subir
até aos quartos e estúdios Ou deixar
para garagem
e
quem tá caindo em cima vai ser apanhado
Então já confirmar casa vem aqui e se
você tiver muito mal tá cliente esconder
aqui temos aqui nos estúdios da Ana Será
que ela está aqui escondida no do vidro
né mas temos aqui esse trabalho
alguém tá aqui dentro Como assim nós
tínhamos como alguém aqui dentro é
impossível não é
nada
fácil também como assim debaixo da cama
impossível porque é muito baixa
e não tá ficar difícil não encontrei
ninguém ainda não tem aqui ui caixa
estas Tais esta
confirmar o meu guarda-roupa ninguém
aqui
escondidos mesmo nem vez quando eu aqui
Como assim
e fala tô impressionado ninguém escondeu
aqui em cima mas o que desapareceu com
certeza encontrou alguém sabe onde é que
tu estás Eu acho que o meu ajudante só
queria dormir mesmo agora sim eu vou
encontrar alguém quantas vezes alguém
escondeu aqui embaixo o estado diz cor
acho que vou estar aqui
E aí
eu não sei que vocês estão aqui porque é
isto é
G1
a
[Aplausos]
brincar comigo mesmo é
É só por isso
e
ela termine esta então desta vez eu vou
contar até 20 agora
um dois
três quatro
cinco seis que estão todos aqui
olha a
há 11 12
13 14
dentro da caixa
15 16
19 20 aqui vamos nossos amigos
tem alguém lá em cima que
está aqui dentro que tem alguém aqui não
é um
e tu tem por objetivo
lixar eu não me queixo Ninja foi
encontrada em
o
encontrou mikic Vasco e
e
não dá realmente o primeiro ainda
escorreguei
escorreguei e
o uso que consegue ler aqui só para
confirmar
nada agora
vou apagar as luzes porque se eu
encontrar as luzes acesas já sei que tem
alguém ali na casa também
ajuda já encontraste encontra 10 pessoas
aqui
então trabalhando aqui no meu
caixa
não tem ninguém na caixa no meu armário
confirmar
apanhar é
E aí que eu tô aqui
eu sei que alguém alguém que
o
acesso a Anna cabou nestas caixas né
é uma hipótese possível sinto um copo de
água e
[Música]
em
contraste com espécies de dor muitas
aranhas aí dentro com medo agora não
vale estar pessoal tema de estar impedem
que se
vê lá tá tudo escuro não diz nada ela
tem
uma respiração não deixei Atacama uma
inspiração aqui tá tudo escuro não vejo
nada mesmo comigo
e eu vou entrar eu não quero saber
quem é
eu não adivinho mano eu senti alguma
coisa a dar em cima de mim por favor
veja o tema de alguma coisa mas olha que
uma cama cama cama cama
corajoso Braga
falta nenhuma chato com certeza estão no
perímetro lado de fora bora ver se eles
estiverem aqui são Furiosos 1
o troféu amigos
bora pessoal
eu não posso falar ninguém vai encontrar
aqui ó
Olá pessoal é o seguinte eu tenho aqui
uma casa de arrumos que eu tenho medo de
entrar desde que estou aqui porque ela é
muito escura mesmo com certeza que ela e
uma achado eu tenho quase a certeza
baixar Machado vou falar calma lá sai
branco e
o
gigante encontraram alguém que lugar não
só bilhas de gás Ai eu não sei se alto
no final olha aí que eu nunca entrei
aqui não vale sustos pessoal tem me
assustar é desclassificado
quem tem coragem de se esconder aqui
você quer tiver aqui algo escondido é
maluco e
o assunto tem alguém aqui pessoal quero
Estações sim ou não eu acho que cima não
quero lhe ver eu acho que também não eu
vou lá só levou lá e contraste
o único se tiver cantando também
nunca cheguei aqui eu vou daqui a pouco
não
tem
ninguém aqui
isso quer dizer que
está a chover Ana tem que estar dentro
de casa com certeza é
é a minha pro
e eu espero que ela não esteja aqui
porque senão vai ficar doente e
constipada espero que ela esteja em casa
mesmo mas eu vi tudinho eu encontrei
acho que ela sabe um sítio na casa que
nem
E tu
como assim mas tudo bem
não estava não estava o caso mas pode
dar a pessoa aqui eu posso não ter visto
a
E aí
o Whats
eu
[Aplausos]
sou burra não estou com muito
muito bom para além desses tem eu vou
dobrar 200 para o
E aí
é muito bom meu Deus mundo igual um dois
três quatro e
É
mas não quebra baque da vovó cinco seis
sete oito não sei mas eu estou atrás do
cortinado no quarto do Dark 10un
eu acho que tá tens o maior Mas pior 30
aqui vou eu só agora é para ler mileuros
importante eles vão ser de trabalhar das
né
não há nenhum perigo porque ela é mais
pequena como é que se esconder em
qualquer lugar então preciso tomar muita
atenção a Anna agora Ok vamos ter que
voltar a tomar a decisão vamos começar
por cima ou por baixo eu vou arriscar já
por baixo as luzes estavam acesas a
pouco já sei que alguém do que caça e
e
quando
[Risadas]
[Música]
chega aqui encontrou um homem que
eu não acredito é assim que tu disfarças
por mileuros não sabe o
o que achas que se resultado tu achas
que não ia ter um com seu lixado aqui no
meio Eu
ia te falar com os corretores ai se
resultar uma chata faca que está em
questionário não ia ser nada Óbvio bem
aparentemente já não mais voltará
comprar uma peça para a tua Mota já vou
ter agonia que tem semente mas agora
pode me ajudar a encontrar os outros né
mas é isso
tem que tirar
aqui pois já OK agora está vazio agora
consegui ver só
o ok então todos lá no andar de cima só
pode bom eu sei que tem aqui gente
porque eu deixei a luz do corredor a ser
neste momento que ela está apagada
eu acho que não vou saber as luzes para
nos encontrar Você já se o mesmo
tivesse aqui o caso era
possível e
o
mik estamos as pernas estão a dormir
portanto
dentro do
armário aberto eu não sei porque que eu
continuo a ver o trabalho mais velha mas
depois da Ana ter feito aquela agitada
ela tem que confirmar tudo bem
e ninguém ok é isso para tá aqui não tá
aqui um inchaço Amanhã vamos para
observar vamos ver se isto mês vamos ver
se é um cortinado para normal olha olha
uma respiração pessoal aparentemente
descontinuados respiram então novo
animal da vida selvagem Este é um animal
que Riacho a pancada agora
Calma
o
caso o carro tem que ser fácil encontrar
o homem alternativamente o homem gigante
eu tentar em algum lugar ainda bem que
ele não tem preto oh
E aí
e olha eu deixei a porta aberta a pouco
eu deixei a porta aberta tá fechado
agora Alguém está aqui não vou sujo se
alguém mas estará desclassificada Ok
Caso vocês aqui
atrás da porta não não está tem que
estar aquela lenços é completamente
impossível mas o que estava a dar aqui
Como assim
ninguém estava aqui dentro nem aqui
dentro
possível calma aqui ó
o
Olá casa e Garanhus está sem raízes
agora ao fogo eu pensei que os quadris
do mundo perder Mil delas está não vais
de viagem comigo mas eu faço um café
para gravar porque ele apareceu a chover
aos o que está ali na porta já ouvi ele
deve ter encontrado alguém mas está
esperando a ordem vamos lá o Nick é um
safado onde é que ele estará dentro do
frigorífico é eu vou fechar as portas
porque eu já vi que nenhum deles está
escondido lá fora eu acho que o único
que não ia aguentar tanto tempo a chuva
nem que
olha aqui eu não confio mais zona do
churrasco pode instalar alguém eu com
ela já não me impressiono porque ela
acaba em qualquer sítio agora com o nick
onde é que esses homem adulto grande 101
em cima não pode embora e o
e conhecendo dos como eu conheço eu sei
que vocês estavam escondidos bem perto
um do outro
eu vou tentar aqui mesmo impossível zouk
caça não mas aqui não dá
Ah eu não acredito
e não like you
o
like tu és o maior
eu
ganhei então não
sabe o que aconteceu Esse vídeo é fosco
invisível
pelo esforço 500
meu Deus obrigado
mas pronto ó
Oi Ana Eu vou para o meio da casa eu não
sei se estás a ouvir mas eu vou para o
mês a casa e tu tens que fazer um som
mesmo que eu te consigo encontrar Tu
vais receber $1500 podes fazer o som
agora
tá lá embaixo
possível da voltar aqui
faz outro só agora não não é
[Música]
e o
e
não tem Águas aqui calma aqui no canto
sim aí deu um cartão em cima
e Como assim porque mas foi Saiu of
Óbvio são vendo aí Ana faz mais um
barulho o meu sofá e
É
porque ela tá na mala não
pode eu
não há conflito Ela está na mala de
viagem né não
E aí
eu fui que eu não acredito fala acabei
de perder os 1.500 Estou a Esperar
melhor jogador esconde esconde do Mundo
Melhor
e essa maior esquece nunca mais vez
descobrir nunca mais tá mal que é que
tens tu escolher aí mas
[Aplausos]
foi por isso que eu fui a primeira sido
encontrado
[Aplausos]
eu vou dividir o meu prêmio com os meus
ajudantes o machado eo caso
ficou um canal de todos eles e
de uma chave passem por lá e
inscrevam-se deixa aqui neste vídeo e se
quiserem mais comenta e fiquem bem e até
a próxima